le bâtiment la construction c'est une
impérieuse nécessité aujourd'hui pour la
maintenance des bâtiments pour la
maintenance des logements mais également
une partie de la reconstruction une
partie de la presse et donc il nous faut
les soutenir alors la première des
choses que nous avons faites avec le
ministre de l'économie avec la ministre
du travail
ça a été de sécuriser autant que faire
se peut l'ensemble des travailleurs du
secteur du bâtiment avec l'ensemble des
fédérations nous sommes convenus d'un
guide sanitaires pour permettre là où
c'est possible dans une totale sécurité
des travailleurs
la reprise d'un certain nombre de
chantiers alors même que nous obsède
nous observions qu'à peu près neuf
chantiers sur dix étaient à l'arrêt et
puis vous avez raison de pointer du
doigt des ordonnances que nous avions
prise le 25 mars dernier qui rallongeait
un certain nombre de délais délai de
recours les délais de droit d'urbanisme
les délais de prescription de préemption
et l'ensemble de ces délais vous
monsieur le sénateur vous l'avez mise en
avant vous aviez raison le président
patriat l'a mis en avant il avait raison
le président retailleau l'a mis en avant
et il avait raison également et donc
suite à l'ensemble des ses remontées de
terrain près de trois semaines après le
début de ces ordonnances nous les avons
d'ores et déjà changé et j'ai eu
l'honneur de les présenter ce matin avec
la garde des sceaux en conseil des
ministres ce fameux délai tampon de 1
mois que vous évoquiez lorsque un permis
de construire ou une décision une
autorisation d'urbanisme était donné
nous y avons mis fin ce matin
s'agissant des recours jusqu'à présent
les ordonnances du 25 mars disait que si
un dossier avait encore un délai de
recours en entrant dans la période
sanitaire en sortie de période
sanitaires il y avait non seulement un
délai de 1 mois mais en plus on
repartait à zéro
ça n'était pas possible et donc là aussi
nous avons changé la chose et lorsqu'il
restait dix jours de délai de recours
avant la période sanitaires il restera
dix jours de délai de recours après la
période sanitaire donc nous avons
entendu ces remontées terrain nous vous
en remercions
et nous avons d'ores et déjà corrigé ces
choses il va nous falloir soutenir
continuer à soutenir ce secteur ô
combien important aujourd'hui et surtout
demain